a pesar de la ruptura de este sábado
pasado de Rusia del acuerdo por el
cereal y el grano ucraniano este acuerdo
aunque esté tocado de Muertos sigue vivo
y lo es porque según nos explican ellos
Fuentes del centro de coordinación
conjunto en Estambul el sitio es donde
se inspeccionan los barcos que salen
desde Ucrania ayer mismo serán desde las
puertas ucranianas seis barcos cargados
con cereal y esta misma mañana lo han
hecho dos más todos se dirigen a
Estambul donde los contenidos de estos
cargueros son inspeccionados por el
centro de coordinación conjuntos según
nos explican ellos mismos hasta este
mismo sábado inspectores rusos
ucranianos turcos y de Naciones Unidas
inspeccionaban los contenidos de estos
barcos desde este sábado hasta ahora lo
hacen sin los inspectores rusos que
según explican ellos mismos Son son
puestos al día después de estas
inspecciones pero no participan en las
inspecciones de hecho Rusia dijo ayer
por la noche que era inaceptable que los
cargueros ucranianos saliesen siguiesen
saliendo de los puertos desde Ucrania
Turquía y Naciones Unidas que fueron los
que mediaron para llegar a este
principio de acuerdo en julio siguen
ahora intentando mediar para intentar
cambiar de hacerle cambiar de opinión a
Moscú de una Moscú que salió de este
acuerdo después de que este sábado
Ucrania atacase con hadrones acuáticos a
unos barcos de la flota rusa del mar
Negro